hiyee hiyee viewers hi again this is my
second video a lot of people actually I
posted a video some a couple of months
ago on YouTube about me speaking
different languages
I tried trying to speak 8 languages and
this is the second video because I'm
actually fine out there's a lot of
people who like my first video and
actually encouraged me to post another
video and so I thought it might have
been a very good idea to you know
suppose some other videos each were
every language because the first video
I'm speaking but at the end video I'm
kind of exhausted because you know as it
like speak they loved it in the end like
my Russian came out not so well so I
would just wanted to have to make it
better be about my Russian war on her
languages and I didn't actually specify
in the first video because I actually
didn't have the time to tell you why and
how I learned English and I learned
English I started learning English when
I was 10 at school by my teacher she's
like so much that basically and then
learned anything for 3 years and then
all of a sudden no one
girl from Chicago came home and she was
my private teacher teacher for a year or
less and she taught me a lot of things a
lot of things improved a lot we remember
that year was wonderful and then she
left me I left back for she gap she went
back to America the United States
tonight I was a little bit you know
disappointed because I want to learn
more I was very greedy as far as you
know English was concerned I tried to
read or watch television I remember that
this kind of language monster was bought
on the bike of the back of my aunt gave
me a book when I was 14 I was not very
into the English language until for more
or less 13 because I thought that
possible to learn language that
Professor Alex ox I don't know how I'll
learn it and then I found now that that
book really like I don't know gave me
kind of a shock and I started to learn
it in that she came was a wonderful girl
for every I'm she came and helped me
helped me out the learning thing and
then I really you know I just started
programs and I watched movies and I read
a lot of books and this started the
whole process and right now I can speak
English I'm speaking very much right now
I'm speaking much more French actually
every day because I got
French Guinea but anyway I think you
understand me when I speak in a lot of
people asking for example why do you
have an American accent and I always
answer no I think it's like watching
videos you know I can absorb accents
without really being aware of it
sometimes by myself talking in some kind
of accents which my friends have for
example in French or another languages
in Swedish for example I people film
because they didn't realize it that I
have a stockholm accent you can even see
it you know some comments posted on the
first video which I'm a is like okay I
got stop the max I didn't know it but
and I want to tell you that as far as
the English language is concerned
there's a couple of major problems I
need to like I think that English
language from a certain point of view is
very simple it's got a simple structure
a simple grammar and it's a language it
is easy to communicate with a but it's
very difficult to master because you got
a lot of you know it's got a huge
vocabulary and this is the first and
main problem and well it's not a main
problem but I mean and the main problem
is its pronunciation because you can
speak lady never language but you
pronounce it
in a poor way nobody would understand
you and improvisation is difficult
because every word it supposed to be
pronounced in a different way you don't
know which I'm across are working enough
why how you're supposed to pronounce it
so that's that's the main problem of
English language not like black or
Italian or Spanish or every language
that I know that once you've gotten it
she's got the pronunciation straight you
can't pronounce every word come across
worried you know how to pronounce it in
English it's not like this
furthermore you have a lot of you know
different accents and different things
of kind of it's not it's an easy
language to communicate with but it's
not that easy as a lot of people think
because it's everywhere of course people
learn you know my name is everybody
knows it but you know if you have to
make yourself understood to get for your
message in a more subtle way it's going
to be a little bit more complicated and
well more or less that's what I wanted
to say there's a lot of things which I
could you know say at but if you want to
ask me we're more than willing to share
whatever I know whatever interesting I
know about the language I really thank
you for listening to me again hope I
didn't bore you and then talk to you
soon in the next video which is going to
be a bellyful thing so bye y'all and
thank you so